I saw where you were criticized that
maybe you enabled Kobe Bryant that and
you were put in a pretty tough position
I got young kids that I want to see if
they can play develop him but this was
always this was Kobe's farewell song and
I'm curious what management wanted from
you did they want you to let Kobe be
Kobe and you know even though he wasn't
a great player or consistent player is
that communicated to you as the head
coach of here's priorities here but not
necessarily mission I really never
talked about that we knew it was his
last year so as I stated before is my
main objective you know was to make sure
he got to that last game and I knew I
had to cut his minutes down I knew I had
a little bit of a balancing act with him
any young guys but I tried to make it as
easy as possible for you know for that
transition but I also knew there was
gonna be a number of games that he
wasn't gonna be able to play swords will
give a lot of these young guys even more
of an opportunity to go out there in
place so you know Mitch or Jim or
anybody never really came to me in
silica we want you to play in less play
more play they just basically let me do
it the way I felt was was the easiest
for Kobe and for the younger guys and
like I said at the beginning when not
even at the beginning then it at
November when he told me that this was
his last year is when I really started
thinking about making sure that I could
preserve him to get to April 13th and
that that was the biggest thing that I
wanted to do and I and I asked him I
said Kobe you got to be perfectly honest
with me in games you can't play you know
because your body is just killing your
aching and the games that you do play
I'm gonna hold you to a certain amount
of minutes your every single night
because I want you to get to that last
game and I want you better to play the
last game and walk off this court the
way you should
what were you putting the best team out
there do you think every night knowing
what that Kobe what didn't want to come
out and you also had to develop these
kids right not all the time I mean that
that's almost impossible to do you know
if you're trying to if you're trying to
preserve one of the greatest players
who's ever played the game but you're
also trying to develop the young guys
you know so it is a little bit of a
juggling act you know but
you know I did the very best that I
could do with that situation because
like I said I wanted him to get to that
last game and I warned him to walk off
that court standing but I also wanted to
get these young guys a chance to develop
in a nice way I wanted them to keep you
know getting better each month and not
take those you know those steps
backwards and I think for the most part
when you talk about the young guys that
we had on that team I think for the most
part all those guys developed nicely and
got better as the season went on and
Kobe was able to go out the way that he
wanted to go out if you just had those
young kids you don't have Kobe do you
still have a job
I don't know you know I really don't
know because you just don't I think you
were in a difficult position is what it
didn't feel fair is what I'm saying here
Byron well I appreciate that but you
know like I said even after the season
was over you know I understand this
business you know I know how this
business is and there's really nothing
that happens in this business anymore to
shock me there's things that kind of
surprise me but there's nothing really
shock you weren't surprised when you got
fired I wasn't shocked you were
surprised I was a little surprised but
you know like I said it when I got home
and I thought about it woke up the next
morning you know you know there's only
two things you can do you either sulk
about it or you move on you know and I
chose to move on and that's how I've
done in my whole life you know every
time you get knocked down I get right
back up and that's what I plan on doing
this year for the rest of my life Byron
Scott former Laker head coach joining us
here in the studio so you played for the
Lakers in the 80s and and I when you're
watching those games the ball movement
then you have some Golden State is
moving the ball and people think it's
this incredible new style now they're
shooting threes but you guys ran all the
time mmm constantly moving and the
Celtics even move ups a little fast
break absolutely so when did we lose
this movement transition fast-break
points because now Golden State's being
hit you know they're hailed is oh my God
look at this new type of offense right
all they're adding is the three-point
element row moving the ball in five guys
touching it and they're add an element
of small ball sort of speak you know
with draymond being able to play the
center position on the defensive end
and really draw everybody out on the
offensive in but it's nothing new I mean
like you said that was things that we
did back in the 80s and when you
mentioned Boston you know we ran a fast
break with magic had the ball 90% of the
time because he's the best playmaker in
the game that I've ever seen and we ran
a motion offense to get up and down the
floor to try to get quick and easy
baskets but if we didn't we always
reverse the ball the Boston Celtics did
it with the pass you know they basically
tried to pass it up the sideline and get
into their office that way so this is
nothing new that we're seeing the only
thing that's new like you said is that
you know you're seeing a multitude of
three-pointers and you're seeing a lot
of small ball by certain teams so I
don't know we're in the transition that
we lost that you know from the 80s till
the present date but obviously something
that's been kind of gradually getting
away from us and the way the game is
played today I think this is a fun style
obviously but you got to have the
personnel to do it if you don't you know
you can't everybody can't be Golden
State everybody can't be San Antonio
Spurs you know so you got to find out
what's best for your team to be you know
successful because if you try to mimic
them with the players that you have and
you don't have those players and it's
not gonna work well that's why would
they say Luke Waltons coming to the
Lakers and he's gonna bring Golden State
style I said you better bring hostei
players it's not gonna work yeah you
know you got to get guys that played
that style and is used to playing that
style for a number of years and let's
understand the Golden State didn't just
start doing this last year you know when
they won the championship they've been
doing this and those guys have been
together four or five years when you
look at clay and you look at you look at
staff and you look at dream they've been
together for a nice period of time right
now so this is the style that they are
accustomed to it's establish they feel
comfortable playing and if you try to
beat them at their style that's where
you're gonna have problems who would you
rather see face Steph Curry in their
prime Kobe or Michael whoa yeah both
both those guys are killers I mean and
both of them would love to take the
child as a guard and stuff will in their
prime
but that whatever you do I'm gonna do
with it cuz cuz Steph couldn't guard
either one of those guys
no but Mike Mike could guard Steph yes
if Kobe wanted to guard Steph yeah
right yes yeah but see the thing is both
of those guys with Warren Agartha they
was they liked the challenge yes but
like would you know both of them believe
me both of them would love to guarding
back in their prime give me your best
Michael Jordan story Michael Jordan
story
you guys remember Anthony peeler yes
okay so hurry right out of Missouri yeah
so we got Chicago Bulls company in town
and unfortunately I got a sprained ankle
you know and so did you say fortunately
and okay unfortunately I enjoy garden
Mike because he was you know the one
thing I did with Mike because I never
got him pissed off try to kill him with
kindness yeah don't try to talk to him
so they're getting off the bus we're
done with shoot around and we're walking
out and MJ says B Scott what's going on
what's up MJ you said man I hear that
you're not playing tonight so now I
sprained my ankle he said who's guarding
me I said Anthony P Lisa 50 so I told
Anthony Peter listen
MJ he's probably gonna go for about 52
not only so just don't don't piss him
off you know just be cool he had he end
up with 54 so the man could do basically
whatever you want to do on that
basketball court
what's your bird story Larry Bird you
know and a lot of people don't notice
you you probably notice Dan but Larry
Bird was one of the biggest trash
talkers in basketball and a lot of
people say really you know they thought
it was Reggie or Charles Larry Bird talk
more trash on the basketball court
didn't didn't anybody I've never played
against and he told us to he told me two
things one game you know our rotations
double team and Kevin McHale always had
to rotate to the corner and Larry Bird
was the one shooting it you know so he
shot one and I mean I'm trying to block
this shot and he was just telling me
Scott you're a little too late you know
little too late so we plant them in the
last the last plane he says to James
Worthy say you guys don't have to worry
about I'm go right over you said they're
gonna set a screen and we take
and he's telling us to play he's telling
us to play before they even take it out
he summer go right over to that corner
and I'm a catch and I'm shooting I'm a
tired of game I win the game whatever
the case may be they take the ball out
and I think it was either Danny or DJ
late great DJ yeah take the ball out the
man core right to the corner conscious
sata3 bird used to tell people I
remember he told me a story about Xavier
McDaniel mmm he said ax man yeah
excellent get the ball right here I'm
gonna shoot a jumper right in your face
and then he got the ball shot it right
in his face yeah and bird says 2x I told
you I was gonna do pretty good but that
was Larry I mean Larry was just an E and
he was saying such a calm way that you
didn't think it was trash talking but
it's trash talking you're not gonna tell
me you will go over there and shoot the
ball in my face that's trash talking but
he would tell you before the play even
started he just come out and say you
know guys you ain't got to worry this is
where the ball going I'm a catcher over
here and he would tell you to play and
catch it over there and shoot it and I
remember I was in the garden when magic
hit the little baby baby hook yeah and
they're going in the locker room
yeah it was you know how small those
long career and it was just chaos chaos
in the Laker locker room after after he
hit that little baby hook man what a
great the great thing about the salted
Laker rivalry back in those days as we
truly did hate each other we had a real
dislike for and it hates a strong word
but we really had a dislike for the
Celtics as they did for us and you know
when you when you retire and you get a
chance to sit down with some of these
guys you find out why it's because you
you were so much alike you know you had
the same the same goals as far as
winning the championship you had no
agenda you know so you really find out
why you guys you know hate each other so
much and I love those robberies I mean
you know the stuff they would do to us
you know in the locker room where they
would have four showers - didn't work
another - had cold water yeah I mean and
you had towels
you know you posed to get these big
towels to dry off they
your face town hilarious some of the
things they did to us after you've gone
through it and you know we would never
retell a trolley was like nah that's you
know me backing out a bit like give him
no towel kind of all but it was it was a
great it was great for basketball
he's Byron Scott former Laker head coach
his basketball camp at Fullerton College
runs from August 1st through the 5th is
there information as there where they
can go for more information yes there is
they can go to Co Scott you got it over
there I'll weed it out
you got it ok ok new book coming out in
June of next year called for the win
it's always great to see if I can always
I wish you the best the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience